rarely since David down the giant
Goliath with his slingshot as new
technology like unmanned aerial vehicles
parked so much excitement there the
modern militaries are I in the sky but
they also have civilian roles such as
border control environmental and
agricultural surveillance mapping and
disaster relief here off the coast of
Somalia these remotely piloted air
systems can fly for up to 18 hours at a
time hi tech cameras study the
activities of Pirates playing some of
the world's busiest international
shipping lanes or keep watch over the
coastline so that warships can intercept
suspects as they head out to sea with
the role of a computer mouse pilots
kilometres away can pick out the
occupants of a vessel identify the boat
and see whether any weapons are on deck
the advantages of these aircraft are
unquestionable this small and relatively
cheap they fly well out of eyesight and
earshot above all they keep pilots out
of harm's way it is a fantastic added
value it's a game-changer we now have
the ability not only to spot elements
like we did before I'm a former of Recca
pilot so I know this but we do much more
now we are on a permanent basis overhead
which means we see flows flows of
anything so we get information which
allows them to have better intelligence
of what is occurring which then has the
ability to prosecute in different ways
through military means or through
traditional means whatever European
governments acknowledge the need to
develop such pilotless planes weather
for military use or in a civilian
setting yet virtually all those used by
Europe's armies are us made member
states remain focused on their national
defense and a reluctant to integrate
their military forces too deeply this is
slowing the development of technologies
such as these the next generation of
these aircraft medium altitude long
endurance must also be able to fly in
skies used
civilian aircraft without crashing into
them and that poses fresh challenges new
development a technology permits a pansy
a co-ed technology security lon pour
avoir planes energy autos keep it fed
would kill the DJ community the
political community XCOM preferred our
domain me there if you hi Shekhar who've
utilization to capacity faced with the
shortfall many Europeans are turning to
the reaper the us-made equivalent which
also allows access to US intelligence
data but American standards are hard to
certify across the Atlantic so it's
difficult to ascertain whether they're
safe to fly in European skies in the end
if there is no European competition
whatever the technology then there's
nothing to stop the American
manufacturers from raising prices to
help out industry and armies alike here
the European defense agencies been
encouraging nations to develop dual-use
projects with civilian and military
applications focused also on satellite
communications cyber defense or
air-to-air refueling they're useful in a
range of tasks disaster work is one area
dealing with floods fires or earthquakes
other applications include coastal and
environmental surveillance weather
tracking and protecting personal data
and computer systems by exploiting
Julius possibilities nations can get
access to EU funds something they could
not do for defence research and
development alone the president Bruce
Lee technology made on Sunday technology
parfois University of en la défense para
el innovation en de Saville mudando
prison proof yet ready Philadelphia set
in technology militare you see the doc
said to Satan reality Sen reality keeper
meadow 2v2 less energy colony open aoc
the pasco cereal let the foot dbj camino
del a particular business valve an avon
to an ato daughter social distress
specific geometry mode that works at
synergy on 20 different political in
your bed more broadly beyond protecting
Europeans from security threats advanced
technologies like remotely piloted
aircraft are also good for the economy
the defense sector employs some 400,000
people in Europe and generates almost a
million more jobs in other areas the
industry's chief aim is to provide the
capabilities Europe wants to meet its
security needs in an increasingly
unstable world and to provide high tech
solutions in civil settings through
research and development but it can only
help keep watching confidence if there
is investment and longer term
predictability